[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 week-end une
émission pour faire un point sur
l'actualité mais aussi pour proposer des
sorties pour bien finir à la semaine
nous sommes le vendredi 21 janvier au
programme de cette émission
l'éolien n'a pas le vent en poupe
dernier projet en date annulé celui du
parc de prunes et en yvelines la cour
administrative d'appel de versailles a
rendu sa décision le 16 décembre dernier
plusieurs agriculteurs habitants et élus
locaux s'étaient montré défavorable à ce
projet développé c'est une nouvelle
édition de la soirée des métiers et de
l'orientation qui attend les jeunes iny
montain dans quelques jours organisé par
le pôle jeunesse de montigny le
bretonneux la soirée a pour but
d'informer collégiens étudiants et
jeunes diplômés sur leurs possibilités
et deuxième partie de cette émission ne
vous proposeront comme chaque vendredi à
des idées de loisirs dans les yvelines
pour bien finir la semaine et ce sera
avec vous ou bixente mais rien senti
stevan est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner déjà un aperçu de ce que vous
nous avez concocté oui justin on va
aller parler musique et on va aussi se
promener en haute vallée de chevreuse
aujourd'hui donc à petit tour en forêt
en tout cas ce sera dans un instant et
puis juste donc pour la partie loisirs
avec vous mais tout de suite voici
l'actualité dans les yvelines
il n'y aura pas d'éoliennes à prunes et
en yvelines si le projet du parc éolien
justement était ton projet en étude
depuis plusieurs années il n'a pas plu
aux administrés la cour d'appel de
versailles a rejeté le projet en
décembre dernier ont fait le point sur
ce sujet un peu controversé donc avec
vous anne cabri bonjour bonjour je le
rappelle un vous êtes et la présidente
vous du parc naturel régional de haute
vallée de chevreuse le projet date d'il
ya à peu près une dizaine d'années en
était à l'étude au départ il était
question d'une dizaine d'éoliennes après
un le nombre est passé à 4 pour faire
accepter le projet la taille également à
diminuer on est passé à 135 mètres de
hauteur mais finalement ça n'a pas suffi
pourquoi selon vous est-ce qu'ils
avaient aussi j'ai cru comprendre une
idée une problématique de sécurité
aérienne ou quelque chose comme ça avec
merci pour votre invitation et nous
donner l'occasion de m'exprimer sur ce
sujet qui me tient à coeur comme vous
l'avez rappelé ça fait dix ans déjà que
ce projet éolien sur prune et en
yvelines et était à l'étude ou la verra
bien rappeler dix éoliennes à l'époque
et une fine et c'était 4 éoliennes ce
projet m'interpelle beaucoup parce que
clairement on s'est positionné dans le
sud yvelines
sûr
l'entrée de la promotion là dessus
pourquoi parce que en un cadre de vie à
préserver les habitants du secteur tout
de suite
on monte un collectif et se sont dit non
c'est pas possible les agriculteurs
également n'était pas pour ce projet il
faut rappeler juste que la chambre
d'agriculture régionale d'île de france
avait pris une délibération dans ce sens
en disant nous on est contre les projets
éoliens en général sur notre territoire
et les élus dont je représente s'étaient
positionnés tout de suite en disant non
pourquoi pourquoi tout simplement parce
que on est sur des plaines de la beauce
et le côté remarquable de nos paysages
des natures et on sait que nous sommes
dans des zones peu denses mais c'est
vrai qu'on s'était tous mobilisés là
dessus et donc là du coup la décision a
priori a été rendu donc on le disait en
décembre qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence selon vous qu'est-ce qui a
fait pencher justement la balance la
balance pas dessus
c'était un un arrêté du préfet de redon
juillet 2018 où il y avait un avis
défavorable c'était le ministère des
armées parce que nous sommes dans une
zone d'entraînement pour les
hélicoptères et c'était dangereux pour
eux en termes de sécurité donc nous
sommes ravis que ce projet ne sortent
pas mais il faut être très attentif
parce que cela nous a pas échappé que la
ministre barbares banque pompili cours
en 2021 a demandé au préfet d'inonder la
france d'éolien donc on va crier
victoire qu'à demi mots on a déjà un
parc éolien pas très loin alain biello
bois ou en a cinq éoliennes qui sont
sortis pendant le confinement donc je
reste prudente prudente mais moi ma
position en tant que mère d'orson vie
d'élu local du sud yvelines n'a pas
changé et je trouverais que ce serait
intéressant quand même d'interpeller
certains de nos collègues élus dont
notre député or berger une clarification
parce que elle l'avait dit en 2017
qu'elle était contre ce projet et si je
ne m'abuse pendant le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro on a eu la possibilité
deux fois sur des lois que ce soit la
loi 3ds ou la loi climat résigne ans où
il ya d'un focus éolien et à ces deux
moments elles n'étaient pas présents
dans l'hémicycle donc quelle est sa
position aujourd'hui elle est quand même
porte parole de groupe la république en
marche à la santé qui était pour
remettre de l'éolien encore plus donc ça
sera intéressant de connaître sa
position aujourd'hui parce qu'en 2017
elle était contre comme beaucoup des
lieux du secteur donc aujourd'hui ma
position est constante et comme on l'a
rappelé et comme il a été dit clairement
si par valérie pécresse je partage
totalement il faut aujourd'hui avoir une
vision sur l'éolien au cas par cas c'est
à dire que un projet éolien ne dois pas
me abîmé un territoire il faut la
validation des habitants des élus et
comme il a été rappelé qu'elle porte
dans son programme c'est exactement de
pouvoir mettre dans les plans locaux des
organisations vous savez des documents
administratifs qui permettent aux
habitations de s'implanter b2dix rate un
endroit on ne mettra pas de l'éolien il
faut que les choses soient bien écrite
après il peut y avoir peut-être dans
certains endroits mais en ce qui
concerne nos territoires ce sud yvelines
auquel je suis très attaché je trouve ça
le dénaturer on le voit par les cinq
éoliennes conte à allainville où c'était
vraiment par rapport à vous de ces
contres mais quand vous êtes le monde
mais en tout cas pour l'environnement
surtout en par rapport à ça par rapport
aux côtés paysage est aussi
l'artificialisation des terres
aujourd'hui moi je suis élu à la région
on a boat est le 06 fitial si on est on
sait très bien que comme et des
éoliennes il ya quand même en artificier
à 10 des terres dont même les
agriculteurs sont opposés donc je me dis
si eux c'est sur 100 sur leur terre n'en
veulent pas donc
moi je trouve que non ses côtés agricole
faire attention mais j'entends que on a
besoin d'énergie renouvelable aussi
également pour pouvoir subvenir à notre
consommation d'énergie l'ajustement je
voudrais rebondir là dessus parce que
finalement il ya eu beaucoup de projets
dans les yvelines qui ont été avortées
justement sur l'éolien
donc là on a dit on est contre le projet
été apportées mais qu'elles sont
finalement les alternatifs dont vous
voulez venez parler il en faut
finalement pour fournir aux foyers à
l'électricité quelles sont les
alternatives
alors on l'a vu en début de mandat
fessenheim a été terminée a été fermé et
là aujourd'hui on entend qu'il faut ré
ouvrir donc bon moi j'ai toujours
considéré que le nucléaire était une
possibilité était nécessaire aujourd'hui
en france mais pas que comme vous l'avez
dit donc il faut des énergies
renouvelables sur notre territoire il ya
deux types d'énergie qui peuvent bien
fonctionné c'est le panneau
photovoltaïque bien évidemment pas sur
les terres agricoles parce que nous
avons des cultures qui ne sont pas
appropriés mais on a plein de zones
d'activités vous êtes d'accord et sur
ces zones d'activités da les toits sont
libres et on pourrait pourquoi pas
mettre du soleil et on a le second focus
ce sont les unités de méthanisation
on en a une qui en cours de construction
sur sur mon territoire à son chant qui
va réinjecter dans le réseau du gaz ce
faire donc voilà on entend pouvoir en
mettre beaucoup mais une unité de
méthanisation qui va pouvoir là ça va
être injecté sur le réseau de
rambouillet c'est important donc ce sont
des nouvelles façons de réfléchir pour
demain peut-être un dernier mot avant de
vous quitter sur cette nouvelle fonction
ans je disais donc vous avez pris la
présidence du parc naturel régional de
la haute vallée de chevreuse en quoi
consistent ces nouvelles fonctions et
qu'elles sont finalement les actualités
à venir sur ce parc alors moi j'ai été
ravie d'avoir été élu en octobre dernier
c'est un nouveau défi mais c'est en
complément de ce que je fais aujourd'hui
tout ce qui touche l'environnement ce
qui m'interpellait en prenant cette
présidence c'est de remettre au centre
du dispositif les élus dont les maires
parce que je me suis rendu compte quand
je me suis promené dans les 53 communes
du parc que les mains on les avait un
peu oublié et il ya certains maires dans
sur curd yvelines par exemple
comme ils ont été rattachées à préaux
côté historique du parc est belle ne
sont pas trop dans les discussions donc
j'ai fait en novembre dernier une
réunion j'ai réuni 53 mergen avait une
quarantaine et on a échangé parce qu'ils
sont élus de situation le parc doit être
un facilitateur et pour répondre à votre
question ce qui a été enclenché là il ya
trois sujets la révision de la charte
qui va être lancée avec une date il
finit en 2026 il va y avoir là tout
simplement a lancé en artois l'été les
aides agricoles et une aide sur la
labellisation et qui reste pour les
centres équestres avec le bien-être
animal et ensuite la charte forestière
la charte forestière est importante
parce qu'on est sur le massif de la
forêt de rambouillet comment on peut
mettre la filière sylvicole
en lien avec la propriété privée la
propriété publique donc on a commencé on
a une réunion qui va continuer dans une
dizaine de jours hélas la semaine
dernière je trouve que c'est un axe sur
lequel il faut réfléchir aussi l'europe
en à bazoges la maison jean monnet
connaissez avec une volonté du parlement
de travailler sur la culture le
patrimoine
je les ai rencontrés donc on est en
train de réfléchir sur pourquoi pas un
partenariat pour mettre en avant mais le
savoir-faire du parc cette pépite de
l'europe avec toute l'histoire connaît
sur notre territoire donc voilà en a
plein de projets j'ai plein de projets
en tête un partenariat pourquoi pas mais
l'hippodrome de rambouillet qui est
labellisé que res également pour
permettre aux habitants des villages
d'aller voir les chevaux qui est cet
échange vraiment d'éducation
d'environnement et de tourisme ce
territoire parfait donc plein de projets
à venir pour cette année 2022 et pour
vos nouvelles fonctions donc tout à fait
merci beaucoup et un cabri d'avoir été
avec nous au je le rappelle vous êtes
donc la présidence la présidente du parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous
que s'est il passé dernièrement dans les
yvelines retour sur l'actualité de la
semaine du 17 au 21 janvier dans le
département le résumé de mélanie poquet
et mickaël millero regarder
[Musique]
face à explosion du nombre de
contaminations le vaccinodromes de saint
quentin en yvelines a ouvert le 10
janvier dernier une zone de dépistage
500 tests antigénique par jour là ils
disent bloqué pour un bras de fer le
cirque zavatta douchez a stoppé la
circulation pour obtenir une
installation après une réunion avec le
préfet les yvelines il a obtenu gain de
cause ce sera sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines il aurait lire
à saint cyr l'école assange armand les
les premières rames du tram 13 ont
commencé à circuler pour les tests la
mise en service est prévue à l'été 2000
22 c'est une première dans les yvelines
la ville de carrières sous poissy s'est
vu remettre le label villes engagées
contre le sida un moyen de rendre plus
visible à lui des collectivités contre
le vih une enseignante de sciences de
collège de trappes exfiltré de son
établissement du département la raison
un cours sur l'évolution de la boue elle
avait montré une photo du chanteur
soprano un cours ayant entraîné des
menaces sur les réseaux sociaux la
décision date de novembre à date de
l'audience en appel n'est pas encore
fixée des absences d'enseignants
surveillants et de personnels
administratifs à cause de lakovic 19
face à cette situation l'académie de
versailles compte embaucher 500
personnes parmi les retraités de
l'éducation nationale et les jeunes
diplômés
[Musique]
et l'avocat de l'enseignante de très peu
mentionné a donc dans cette dans ce
résumé de l'actualité de la semaine
étaient reçus à 17h aujourd'hui par le
secrétaire la secrétaire général de
l'académie et le cabinet de la rectrice
nos fonds point lundi à 18h en direct
dans notre journal d'information et dans
le cadre du mois de l'orientation
organisé par le pôle jeunesse de
montigny le bretonneux les jeunes il y
monte un sont invités à la soirée des
métiers et de l'orientation ça se
passera le 26 janvier prochain objectif
s'informer sur leur avenir professionnel
le reportage de céline charles le
mercredi 26 janvier de 17h30 à 20h30 la
commune de montigny le bretonneux
organise une nouvelle édition de sa
soirée des métiers et de l'orientation
elle se déroulera à l'hôtel de ville
organisée par le pôle jeunesse la soirée
est ouverte à tous les aînés montant de
la 4e aux étudiants et jeunes diplômés
les destinataires de cet événement soit
évidemment les jeunes de 13 à 25 ans
mais aussi leurs parents qui les
accompagnent qui ont si souvent beaucoup
de questions objectif informer sur
l'orientation la réorientation les
métiers l'apprentissage ou encore le
service civique avec des stands
d'information des conférences des
témoignages des temps des changes impôts
le projet d'orientation projet
professionnel voilà avec des
informations individuels avec des
professionnels de l'orientation il faut
parler alternance
découverte des métiers formations dans
le cadre d'un projet en particulier il
ya un deuxième pôle qui est le pôle
découverte des métiers
et surtout donc des métiers bien sûr
mais aussi des outils qui permettent de
clarifier un petit peu cette question là
de trouver des familles des familles de
métiers en fonction des goûts des
aptitudes des affinités du profil il ya
un troisième pôle qui est celui de la
mobilité en europe et du volontariat
voilà on abordera la question du service
civique
du service national universel voilà
entre autres y aura un pôle information
en accès libre avec des expositions qui
vont aborder la question clarifier de
pakour sup de l'orientation après la
troisième du post bac en bonus un escape
game spécial orientations sur le thème
de star wars sera prévu accès libre sous
réserve de présentation d'un pass
sanitaires veulent de
légal checking c'est la rubrique
hebdomadaire à qui vous décrypte une
actualité politique une chronique de
raphaël mata duvignau membres de
l'association est les surligneurs mais
aussi maître de conférences en droit
public aujourd'hui il s'est intéressé à
la proposition de réforme des droits de
succession de jean luc mélenchon
notamment la mise en place d'un héritage
maximale de 12 millions d'euros regardez
jean luc mélenchon explique ce qu'il
compte faire une fois élu président de
la république au delà de 12 millions
d'héritage je prends ton avons qu'il
n'en est pas à son coup d'essai en
matière fiscale et les surligneurs
relève régulièrement ses propositions
démesurée
la mesure annoncée prendrait la forme
d'une loi modifiant le barème des droits
de succession ce barème est relativement
complexe car il tient compte à la fois
du montant de la succession et durant de
l'héritier par rapport aux défunts les
héritiers en ligne directe sont les
moins taxés alors que les cousins
éloignés peuvent être imposées jusqu'à
hauteur de 60 % de plus ce barème ce
calcul autour de cette branche
progressive la première exonérés ou un
autre et bras la plus haute dites
marginales imposé à 45 % au-delà de 1
million 800 mille euros d'héritage avec
sa proposition jean luc mélenchon
souhaite créer une 8ème tranche à 12
millions d'euros avec un taux
d'imposition de 100% et c'est là tout le
problème
le conseil constitutionnel juge depuis
longtemps qu'au delà d'un certain
montant l'impôt serait confiscatoire est
contraire à la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen ce principe a été
plusieurs fois confirmé et notamment en
2012 lorsqu'il avait été question de
créer une tranche marginale 45% pour
l'impôt sur le revenu à partir de 150000
euros de revenus annuels
alors une question se pose à partir de
quel montant un impôt devient-il
confiscatoire
malheureusement répondre à cette
question est beaucoup plus difficile
qu'avant c'est une promesse électorale
inconstitutionnelle en effet le montant
d'impôt et analysé au regard non
seulement de son taux mais aussi des
autres impôts pouvant s'appliquer à la
même matière imposable par exemple le
conseil constitutionnel a jugé
confiscatoire un taux de 77 %
d'imposition sur les stock options ou de
82% sur les plus values immobilières par
conséquent une réforme créant une
tranche de 100 % l'imposition serait
immanquablement jugé contraire à la
constitution
jean luc mélenchon persiste avec ses
nombreuses promesses fiscales
inconstitutionnelle un surnom lui paraît
donc tout trouvé confisqué à tort
et après l'actualité c'est l'heure de
vos idées loisirs pour le week-end
et le week-end dans l'est dans les
yvelines c'est avec vous bixente mérian
santisteva mme vous avez donc concocté
un petit programme pour ce week end
aujourd'hui on sort se promener en hiver
mais justin l'hiver il fait froid certes
mais si vous êtes bien couverts rien de
mieux que en ce moment que de faire une
petite balade une petite marche voire
pour les plus courageux une petite
randonnée même c'est l'occasion de
prendre l'air d'enlever le masque nous
on doit porter en plateau et dans les
yvelines en trouve plein de lieux
propices à cette activité par exemple au
parc naturel de la haute vallée de
chevreuse alors nous qu'est ce qu'on a
fait justin on est parti avec une caméra
un téléphone et des chaussures peut-être
un peu trop blanche et sa massue après
pour vous donner un petit aperçu de ce
qu'il ya à découvrir là bas départ à
cerner la ville près du salon léopold
regarder avec ses 8 115 kilomètres
carrés le parc naturel de la vallée de
chevreuse est un grand espace regroupant
notamment la vallée de chevreuse et la
forêt de rambouillet pour en parler nous
vous le soleil boivin bonjour bonjour
vous êtes guide de park et je suppose
que vous connaissez dans les environs
énormément de balades et de promenades
et de randonnées à faire oui exactement
on a vraiment beaucoup de chance d'être
sur ce territoire
très varié qui
qui nous permet d'avoir beaucoup de
randonnées affaires et en termes de
faune et flore on est en plein hiver
qu'est ce qu'on peut voir en ce moment
alors même en plein hiver à la forêt est
riche de plein d'animaux on a des
oiseaux qui viennent passer l'hiver ici
notamment les terrains des aulnes ou
encore sur sur les étangs on peut
observer des oiseaux qui sont assez
rares donc là si je veux partir faire
une petite promenade c'est l'hiver j'ai
pas envie d'avoir froid trop longtemps
mais quand même pour me rafraîchir
qu'est ce que voit ce que je vais d'ici
alors au départ du petit moulin du
parking du petit moulin au niveau du rue
des veaux c'est vrai qu'il y à une
grande diversité de balade on peut faire
des petites boucles de 2 km pour ceux
qui ne veulent pas marcher longtemps
jusqu'à plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres
sans problème est peut-être un petit
site aussi de patrimoine bâti qu'on peut
voir dans les environs alors il ya la
balade des moulins qui propose long du
rue des veaux six moulins à découvrir et
on peut également monter jusque dans la
carrière des maréchaux pour voir les
traces du passé merci beaucoup solène
boivin et nous on va s'empresser d'aller
marcher un peu se promener un peu et
découvrir les plantes sauvages
comestibles avec stéphane loriot
bon concert avec stéphane loriot
animateurs patrimoine aux pme bonjour
bonjour est ce que le pnr est riche en
terme de plantes sauvages comestibles
par définition oui ce n'est pas un
endroit unique la tempe de plantes
sauvages comestibles mais l'endroit s'y
prêtent davantage évidemment on va aller
en découvrir quelques-unes vous pouvez
nous en montrer à proximité là
donc là nous avons par exemple la
stellaria médias
avec ses petites fleurs blanches en
forme de l'étoile caractéristiques qui
peut faire trois quatre cinq cycles dans
l'année c'est une plante annuelle qui
résiste au froid les jolies sont faibles
et vous avez ici donc ce premier cycle
de cette plante qui en préparation
froide et constitue l'une des meilleure
salade en préparation froide europe
alors vous avez si de nouveaux cette
belle rose est de cardamines pire suite
op
[Musique]
voilà déjà ce goût piquant aux
caractéristiques amer parce que votre
plante sauvage cette amertume que l'on
recherche et la chaude ou froide la
préparation vraiment intéressant que
vous omettez 10 15% dans la préparation
vous avez un condiment qui se
rapprochent envie de vous dire de la
moutarde ou du piment ok mais ça va on
dirait
salade avec un petit bout de prêts sans
intérêt voilà c'est la même famille ça
tombe hier au caire oui aille en arrière
goût qui pique un peu et voilà et
c'était un goût amer et qui picote va
rester en bouche après un petit quart
d'heure d'accord et c'est souvent le cas
avec les plantes sauvages les plantes
sauvages sont en regardant ce que nos
plantes cultivées est somme la plus
rustique mais qui dit rusticité dit
notamment complémentaires alimenta pas
comment dire en termes de literie mans
les plantes sauvages sont deux à être
plus nourrissante que nos plantes
cultivées et c'est ce qui fait leur
force dans les temps en futur elles ont
leur place pour complémenter notre
alimentation qui n'est pas au meilleur
au fil des années
[Musique]
à
là vous avez un sol humide tromper toute
l'année vous avez la cardamine amer la
cardamine caméra qu'il y a qui poussent
dans les sols trempé et là en termes de
saveur piquant poivre et pimentée c'est
vraiment je pense aussi ce qui a mieux
c'est ce que nous avons de mieux en
europe tout simplement
elle est succulent amer évidemment
pimenté poivre et comme tout bon comme
rarement et qui reste en bouche extrême
en utah voyage l'attak qui piquent
énormément enfin expliqué normalement ça
dépend de sa sensibilité mais qui menait
mais ça c'est pendant ces web et là vous
pouvez fabriquer des sauces froides ou
chaudes vraiment ça c'est plus pour
faire des sauces c'est une plante
cousine qui relèvent le goût dans un
plat sans relief la plupart des cas
évident mais sauf que le goût des arts
est différent par contre le deuxième
goût à bas le deuxième ça c'est mais le
produit on dirait qu'on prend un petit
peu de moutarde ouais quand même louis a
un petit côté moutarde de dijon pour lui
les prix
alors discrètement mais est tout de même
vous avez ici de gaye et gratuit donc
cette plante en dessous pour velouté
vraiment vraiment intéressante et puis
en salade hachez finement mais non
[Musique]
voilà donc vous avez maintenant quelques
idées de promenades ici dans le parc
naturel de la vallée de chevreuse elles
peuvent faire plusieurs kilomètres ou
même quelques centaines de mètres si
vous souhaitez vous arrêter sur les
plantes sauvages comestibles
il suffit de venir au parc seul ou même
accompagné d'un guide pour avoir plus de
précision avec eux
donc là on s'est pas mal arrêté sur les
plantes sauvages comestibles mais comme
disait la première intervenante du sujet
solène boivin il ya aussi l'observation
de la faune et la flore le patrimoine
bâti pour choisir quel randonnée vous
souhaitez effectuer dans le parc il y à
une application web plutôt pas mal qui
est proposé vous avez plusieurs
distances une petite idée de ce qu'il ya
à voir selon les randonnées ces randos
point pnr tirer idf.fr elle devrait
s'afficher en bas de l'écran normalement
très bien en tout cas pour les
chaussures blanches vous le saurez pour
la prochaine fois à bixente et je crois
que j'ai récupéré une petite photo de
vos chaussures sont peu meules affiché à
l'écran voilà on ne peut les voir est-ce
que je sors miss bixente vos chaussures
pour ma part oui pour margot qui était
avec moi c'est peut-être un peu plus
grave et j'en profite pour les remercier
d'être venu tourner ce petit reportage
margot jésus est bon en tout cas après
s'être dépensé bixente il est le temps
un peu de se poser est pourquoi pas au
théâtre coluche de plaisir mozart y
prendra place et ce sera le 29 janvier
prochain mais avec son très célèbre
opéra les noces de figaro cette pièce en
quatre actes de trois heures est
présenté par l'opéra nomades nous avons
discuté avec son chef d'orchestre et
directeur amaury du closel voici son
interview express
[Musique]
une critique sociale extrêmement
violentes contre le du peuple si vous
voulez contre l'aristocratie en nous
rapprochant le plus possible de la
manière dont le mother éventuellement qu
entend tout ça tout ça va être une sur
deux représentations de l'auterne n'ont
pas de l'authenticité à l'ancienne mais
tout simplement d'essayer de retrouver
les qualités de couleurs le de les types
d'articulation et l'expression du xviiie
siècle
[Musique]
l'opéra et par la paire nature un genre
qui n'est pas simple parce que
il ya des chanteurs il ya beaucoup de
trouver les mots qui sont ensemble pour
que ça marche mais pas toujours en
général le miracle est toujours vieux et
donc on s'aperçoit que c'est c'est au
contraire une oeuvre d'art totale qui
mélange le chant la musique la mise en
scène de théâtre les décors les costumes
les pieds
[Musique]
et pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas
l'occasion d'aller à l'opéra venait à
l'opéra justement c'est le moment de sa
maman de sortir de chez vous qui est
justement dans les circonstances
présentes où il semble que le variant
soit soit moins - comme moins dangereux
vous pouvez venir bien protégés et vous
aurez un spectacle qui vous réjouit le
coeur
[Musique]
et dans la journée à venir vouliez nous
parlait aussi bixente d'un autre concert
à venir oui le premier concert de
l'année des solistes de lavilledieu avec
marianne piketty au violon emmanuelle
bertrand au violoncelle et dana
ciocarlie et au piano le trio nous
plonge dans la période romantique à
coups de mel bonis chaussons mendelsohn
trois virtuoses réunis pour une
représentation ce samedi 22 janvier à 18
heures à l'auditorium du conservatoire
de trappes rien de tel pour être apaisés
transporté pour passer un week-end
serein justin très bien l'écouter c'est
noté je vais essayer de passer un
week-end ce un bon pourquoi pas dès
maintenant chez nt voulu aussi nous dire
un rapide sur un rendez vous qui aura
lieu mardi prochain ce sera un petit mot
sur un spectacle à montigny le
bretonneux le 25 janvier prochain c'est
bérengère krief connu notamment pour son
rôle dans la série bref qui vient du
côté de la salle jacques brel pour son
nouveau spectacle appelé amour où elle
parle d'amour justin ah ça c'est bien
tout est dit votes suspects tout est dit
et pour finir un festival qui débutera
donc le week-end prochain c'est ça on
termine en musique encore une fois ce
dimanche 30 janvier c'est l'ouverture du
15e festival au fil des voix du côté de
la clé des champs à plaisir pour
l'occasion le lieu accueille un jeune
représentant de la musique kurde russe
anne phillips tech frédéric poletto de
le directeur de la salle nous en parle
c'est de la musique traditionnelle un
virtuose de son instrument je n'ai pas
commencé parce que je risque de faire
une erreur mais
voilà une très belle artiste à découvrir
ce à séoul où vraiment sur des musiques
du monde mélange entre musique
traditionnelle et et un musiques plus
modernes
voilà je sais moi je vais pas me risquer
non plus à prononcer son instrument non
c'est une sorte de luth façon
moyen-orient il viendra partager son
univers c'est le 30 janvier prochain a
plaisir à 17 heures eh bien merci
bixente mairesse entité ban pour ces
acides et de rendez vous en tout cas moi
j'ai choisi j'opte pour le week-end sera
merci beaucoup et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi et puis vendredi prochain grégory
à canal et sera de retour avec vous
bixente à vos côtés en attendant vous
pourrez retrouver à le journal de la
rédaction ce sera donc lundi à 18h en
direct sur tb 78 très bon week-end à
tous et surtout prenez soin de vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]